You might remember Donald
Trump's lawyer, Michael Cohen,
for this classic legal argument.
But you guys are down,
-and it makes sense
that there would... -Says who?
-Polls.
-Says who?
Most of them. All of them?
Says who?
(laughter, shouts)
-Boom!
-That is...
-No...
that is maybe some of Hugh
Laurie's best character work.
HARDWICK:
It's so good.
Yeah, you know, the last season
of House got real weird.
-Says who? Says who?
-Says who?
-It's nice to know that if he
or Trump ever get in trouble,
their defense is gonna be:
-"A bitch says what?”
-(laughter)
I like his confidence.
I want to use that the next time
someone tries to break up
with me-- I'll just be like,
-"Says who?"
-(laughter)
(whooping, applause)
Hundred points to Esther
for that.
Now Cohen's tweeting out divine
proof that Donald is gonna win.
This cloud. Hmm.
-And he says...
-(laughter)
And he wrote:
"In case anyone is unsure
"as to who will be
our next POTUS,
the Lord has chosen
the people's messenger.”
(laughter)
And those little tiny
cloud hands at the bottom
are just giving us all
the finger.
(whooping, applause)
Comedians, what's the weather
report for this picture?
-Yes, Jay. -We have a dumb front
moving in from the east.
(laughter)
-(whooping, applause)
-Points.
I can leave it at that.
I'll leave it at that.
Randy.
See, I think it's
more complicated than that.
That is a very difficult
weather system to predict.
It is a severe tornado warning,
-but only for Latinos, so, uh...
-(laughter, groaning)
HARDWICK:
Oh, (bleep).
The cloud knows.
The cloud knows where to go.
And I... I think
those wisps of clouds
were taken from another cloud
-and put on top of that cloud.
Yeah. -And put on top.
-You think it was
a cloud transplant. -Yes, I do.
Esther.
Cloudy with a chance of a guy
who looks like meatballs.
Yes, points!
Very good, very good.